[Music]
I'm sure look you have a grand spectacle
prepared for these fine people but I
must insist that my message is heard
here Evo is the pinnacle of fighting
game competition and this year's
installment gave us its fair share of
highlights now it wasn't all meditation
and peak performance though there were
moments like the G cosplay that made us
cringe just a little bit good evening
people of the earth you may call me G
then there were times when a play did
not quite go according to plan one more
touch no way he got no God I got it and
of course there were the moments that
broke the tension and made us all laugh
that's the look by the way that he's
wearing it GameCube yeah on his neck now
we've got a whole video for you guys on
the highlights combos and pop offs at
this year's competition but today we're
celebrating the best fails and the funny
moments from Evo 2018
Japan will take it babe oh he wants
water break yeah oniy got him oh it was
open Oh evil moment water bottle gonna
struggle for him since the cabinet is
the carrier's nose yeah you don't care
okay sure we live we don't need tissue
oh let's go we don't need tissue Wow
look it up
sorry that was my bad I'm fired
it's actually asked to Jane let's get
s2j up here give it up give it up mind
game the mind games no good calls rush
stage oh [__] myself
yeah coming in everybody's coming in get
your selfie dirty looks then can I only
miss look at the thumbs down everyone
dang you actually show you one get in
here they get on their thumbs down from
Jordan oxide 40% over their rock oh you
got your you know oh we know we don't
you know what I'm spelling I'm not gonna
say though they start knowing this have
Christine
the man with the golden hair cyclops
athletic gaming from Westar pay and talk
to them joking you know funny thing is I
read on Twitter he's art this is a
losers match recently sponsored echo
boxes Harada take a moment everybody put
the eye drops in oh yes I don't know
what's up with this clean up
they've been staring at the screen so
long brother Mitch's but imagine take a
lot out of you made the cake okay then
seen Boone play myself all day I was
talking to Richard Oz I'm considering
asking them if I could have one nice
nice job though from both players
meanwhile Tyson try to counter it with
the shock Benna really Dominican is may
has made it thank God but what's this
this man is feeling them so oh let me
see that
oh yeah the people that don't know for
people that don't know Minna rd1 Capcom
come right again so yeah this is a
loser's bracket whoa what's that
where's that whoa whoa whoa you can't do
that Yeah Yeah come on in sports eSports
I know it's just that we became guys
[Music]
nice reaction ride the end
what is he doing I was so bad Mike oh
wow wow wow yo don't let him talk to you
like that
he's life his career for smash ultimate
before he even starts a net play all
right Matt files oh that was massive
salt its own meat oh this is the meat oh
he's got no meat Oh brand it's not a
cookie what is that a meat Oh brain
snacks live here in Vegas comfortable
there's no way you least a powerup but
take the chloro it isn't stopping
anytime soon so you picked a perfect
time
you're gonna start chillin on our stream
come on man the Japanese players have
been chilling all day it the consistency
is amazing
but it's really not one forgot to
disconnect their disconnected no one
could move it because one of the
previous players know those have got to
forgot to D sync their controllers damn
moving off do it well what a perfect
shirt for today sure there is right so
apparently this was Jack's looking
frightened when she when anna has you in
the handoff so pummel this is premios e
is nowhere to be found
dude are you kidding me you thought was
he was gonna show up I finally did think
five slide I didn't think that it was
you'd be sitting there shame on me you
know it's one of those things fool me
once shame on you
for me seven hundred thousand times
shame on us for not having player
managers brutal forty thirteen Evo
champion
this the sunglasses I told you the lumen
we gotta look at them I suck his pride
and trade on points to the yahoodi sir
the crooked three Japan one American on
the winter side
this is cake food coming all the way
from France the trash dog champ of
France taking the stage I wanted to say
I was gonna say Detroit but I was in
look the hand mix-up was crazy right
there
[Applause]
yeah I think I think he could have held
out on the burst because oh me too only
had level one miss finer so he was
probably gonna have to do something in a
misfire RC he's gotta watch himself
Manor this is a lot of pressure that he
has to deal with
0:03 is it is enough and almost signal
it looked like he was about to be able
to live it unfortunate for him what a
catch from Captain Zack oh whoa whoa
whoa that's look if you're gonna be the
villain you might as well play the part
row
between what the [__] Sue's idols and f
Jeff is gonna be in top a tomorrow
what no he's no I'm talking nonsense I
got so carried away and he almost
brought it all the way back he's vicious
to the last pixel if he fights it out
give it up for your first competitor
jay-z see oh
problems X he so deserves this win okay
[Music]
okay now what what happened what happen
here
I'm sure look you have a grand spectacle
prepared for these fine people but I
must insist that my message is heard
here bathed in the energy of this love
audience and of the thousands watching
at home good evening people of Earth you
may call me gee look guys we've all been
there you finally opened up your
opponent and you know in your mind
exactly how brutal your next combo will
be this is your shot at glory and then
you drop it and he wins the round look
it happens to the best of us literally
maybe a little bit of an option select
if yet exactly the dropkick you would
have absorbed it on the armor from that
Wow incredible
butoh is the best at landing that and
you know he is so willing to use his
meter in every single way possible
god damn huh
all right I've got a step up how did I
win that man oh my god one more touch no
way God God I got it yeah the last frame
minute - animation did look alien barn
what was that I some are what was that
don't ever wake up with super against me
again you know that might also be a
little bit of that costume mix-up look
at the punish on the jump out he caught
him on the command grab for the kill one
hit in the critical art will be able to
take him out that's what Matt working
for a tech firm that really stings Bob
that's intentionally trying to get into
the air to avoid some of the worst
damage by who tried to walk under the
food Oh coming down with the bodies but
oh no it would error not without however
their testing can we go at my commentary
resilience and that's okay because o EP
of evil right there is saving everything
right now
okay okay okay you sensing yeah there's
the first same spot that's guaranteed oh
come on how you gonna do that how you
just gonna so the match look very
competitive and they're all the same
just gonna push units to kill them just
to put them in place Naga is one of like
the best at utilizing instant kill in
the world I don't think there's anybody
better oh my god good kill
if oh no it's not gonna here side wall
save lives but Kenny punished
[Music]
oh yeah animation right players with
names resumes there's pressure that must
be overcome the test
all of a sudden you see the people
strong
oh no chillin I'm gonna go for the
thrill
cuz actual difficult we okay looking
away
oh the sonic world prison real Quinn is
running in into boobs oh no he had the
right idea
did Zach send us into another set you
ain't gonna wait long for the answer
that whoa that's what I like to see
right there it's walking back it forward
mm there is that heavy over there watch
it oh no no he thought it was a regular
jump in justin wong did not he's pretty
punchy look at that a couple can
actually change his jump or seemed to
switch to jump see get back onto the
stage he actually killed that that was
you just trying to recover
[Applause]
you know guys one of the things we love
about the fgc is that they don't take
themselves too seriously all the time I
mean sometimes you just have to forget
about the roar of the crowd at Mandalay
Bay you have to leave aside the sick
combos the upsets the new tech and just
have a laugh here are some of the
funniest moments from Evo on the mic the
rock-paper-scissor battle alright
they're trying to confirm one two three
oh my god did you throw the bait line
yeah do the name of fries
yeah rock-paper-scissors so sick that
rock-paper-scissors is dangerous the NSM
my dudes going paper the most
unconventional you don't think I'm a
swing by MC I am the type of guy that
goes tape a three-time control dance I'm
dangerous live the life like today did
you even think about put some now so
i'ma beat yo ass stay right there we'll
be right back extension I like it not
like this not like this well one of
those guys definitely looks ready to
play some anime video games like play
that go on up against a Kazuma jumo you
know he got a crunchyroll subscription
with a name like that you act like you
don't
[Laughter]
that's like smash equivalent of flavor
flavor which I really respect I liked
his aesthetic and his style GameCube is
not like yeah it's not light these solar
flags I believe so oh man look at that
was like yo I came to Evo expect it to
fight against cell finish boos kill this
man alright we're back you're watching
evolution 2018 before we get the action
started don't forget one of the sponsors
here Geico gaming they'll ensure your
playstation I'm not sure what they'll do
but the best insurance money can buy I'm
not sure what they're gonna insure but
you could count on them
thanks for supporting Evo amigos okay
vs. G off he's gonna get his rocks off -
faster I tell ya wait cooler than 9
this dude Noctis doesn't even like have
muscles yes swords
what would our what would a 13th place
Armani even look like I don't know it is
second best player in the world
as per our most recent rankings actually
is third
they put welcome iron actually didn't
mean it that my man's pistol he actually
got to be sharing his other testicle
with this man that's a real 50/50 right
there I would never claim a Raven player
and soon I think they felt they beat
they sat they shower with with cold
water and salt right like they don't use
so just cold water in salt they keep it
all night around the heartbreak city
when you're trying to break one close to
throws I think someone might is just
like you know if weapon today was
unquestionably the blood the best player
in the world and the best player in the
room just sometimes people say Bobby
Starr you know I don't think that you
know much about the game you're out of
touch you know I don't think that you're
actually that good as a player so Fendi
five to clean lesson called it early on
just saying didn't drop the game well
guys there it is those are some of our
favorite moments that made us laugh and
a few that made us cringe from Evo this
year now if you'll excuse me I need to
go work on my G cosplay does anyone know
where I can get gold face paint thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button